thank you morally bankrupt superhero
dude wears an ironic happy face button
on his robe while making late-night eats
with always riveting middle-east foreign
affairs news story the United States
does not start fights movie gets the
best Nixon impersonator they could find
at your local bar at 3:00 a.m. seriously
I don't care if he's supposed to be in
his fifth term or whatever this is the
least Nixon a Nixon that ever Nixon it's
like the casting director said and for
Nixon find me someone that looks more
like your report or a super old David
Boreanaz what are the chances the
Russians will actually attack the United
States Pat Buchanan movie plays the best
of Dana Carney on Saturday night live
without Dana Carvey director pays homage
to his last hit via hotel room number
vandalism he find out later this is
Ozymandias but this is not Ozymandias
guy who wants to kill comedian waste
time throwing him across the room
instead of out the window which he does
later anyway zack snyder's slow-motion
fetish Incredibles meets lazy flashbacks
meets opening credits montage meets oh
my god this thing is over three hours
long is this a world where Gotham exists
but Batman is only a comic and what kind
of Opera House plasters Batman comics on
its walls anyway okay let's run them
down black haired black widow pussy wing
dude discount cap blind squirrel old man
paperwork cigar bastard misses cigar
bastard and the hangman what a fearsome
group credits shut the signs to remind
me of sky captain in the world of
tomorrow for some reason this movie is
alternate history but this newspaper
headline kind of meshes with regular
history so I'm confused
also in this alternate timeline that Ben
Affleck and Josh Hartnett still fall in
love with the same girl as count Captain
America tragically dies in the DC vs.
Marvel Wars of 1956 the Last Supper shot
only has nine people in it rendering all
the other religious subversion contained
in the picture moon including female
pregnant Jesus suppose it's superhero
can be dragged by two dudes into a car
with no problem looks like John Doe
exists in this reality to newspapers
abbreviating Russian with Rus I know at
least two guys named Russ that would
have a problem with us I can't tell you
how much this single shot inspired x-men
Days of Future past so far this
alternate reality thing has shown me the
same presidents as reality and now the
same Vietnam War when does the timeline
split
wait so someone left this note here with
these two bodies but it only blew away
with the wind just after being seen and
discovered by law enforcement this is
the third super close-up at the smiley
face button this movie's given me in 11
minutes and it's kind of getting
annoying
also all three have involved smiley
faces in blood I'm getting the feeling
this movie does not want me to
happy March Journal October 12th 1985 or
you could just be honest and call it
Rorschach's narration having seen the
incredible height from which comedian
was thrown out of his apartment this
grappling hook has such amazing reach it
gives Batman penis empty no the whole
world stands on the brink way too many
minutes of row shacks terrible Marv from
Sin City narration impression a comedian
died in New York somebody knows why yeah
but does somebody know the meaning of
the word obvious watch the door dude
then immediately walks away from the
door I mean what the is what rack and
previous two bullets first that cop
really that bad of a shot was Nixon
forcing you out did you think I voted
for that prick five times
why 5 turns I kind of feel like even if
term limits were removed America would
never elect the same dude five times in
a row fickle and that would span 20
years with a new generation of voters
and five terms let's talk downstairs the
Batcave I mean the discount Batcave
maybe someones picking off costumed
heroes so the non costume heroes are
getting off scot-free it's a maintenance
hatch that'll let you out two blocks
north
I remember came there often when were
partners
dan tells Rorschach something he already
knows so that were check until Dan
something back that he knows and who was
this dialog for again Oh
mothman's in an asylum in Maine
I guess nobody heard that because it's
raining giant blue ass will not fully
prepare you for all the blue nudity
you're about to consume him in this
movie thing what is he doing right now
anyway why can't he put pants on to do
it you might think I'm gonna sin the
fact that Kara's not dr. Manhattan is a
dick but instead I'm actually sending
the decision to use 99 left balloons as
the soundtrack for said dick nice also
even though history took a major detour
to the Minuteman in the Watchmen 99 left
balloon still exists just keeps getting
further away from me complaining about
your boyfriend - the guy you're going to
later is this the first time he's tried
to do this and she's turned him down
there is it like the 47th and why does
he try this ugliness right after he and
a bunch of other superheroes just posed
for a picture and why did she decide to
undress in the color of money instead of
a bathroom all bad guys are rapists wait
what the fuck is going on here
Watchmen steals the ride of the
Valkyries from Apocalypse Now also when
dr. Manhattan is winning Vietnam he
decides he needs to wear some undies
because his blue dong is a war crime
also straight-up murder
many times over but whatever us hey us
hey why did Manhattan even leave anyone
alive for this asshole to shoot his
handgun at now we must talk I vote it's
baby Jesus how long has Vietnam been
going on with somebody like dr.
Manhattan going around disintegrating
people
this woman's late what seven months
pregnant straight-up murder and somehow
dr. Manhattan did nothing to stop it
you could turn the gun into steam the
bullets into mercury the rapist is right
but an uncomfortable saying he would be
amazing at cinemasins
it seems like a publicity stunt not in
it for the ink already hard I mean
seriously how is the comedian ever
allowed in this crime-fighting group to
begin with he's a grade-a dickhead
through and through I know you're all
superheroes and everything but could you
guys put that fire out this is the
longest funeral ever it's long enough
for three flashbacks movie saves money
on this futuristic fiery riot scene by
just using stock footage of modern-day
Vancouver following a Stanley Cup
Playoffs loss somehow the society is so
fucking angry at superheroes they're
burning them in effigy thanks for saving
our lives repeatedly now die also it
seems like it the Watchmen had just
gotten rid of comedian in the first
place nobody would have gotten mad at
the vigilantes tombstone misspells Harry
D Morton but I guess it did get one name
right well apparently some folks in this
universe have elf ears I did not know
that but okay I guess Rorschach needs to
pick the lock of the cemetery gate when
he has the best grappling hook ever made
Eman groupsets dr. Manhattan definitely
has too many dicks on the dance floor so
well he's sitting on the bed next to her
bra missing her does he still have three
other hims out there working on his
research
I don't know anybody except goddamn
superheroes in this alternate timeline
if you look up firstworldproblems in the
dictionary there's a picture of this
girl's face DC Comics walking down an
alley always means bad guys are waiting
to stir some shit up the movie cuts back
and forth between the alley fight and
dr. Manhattan on television and someone
forgot to tell the director not to do
that at what point does a gang of street
toughs realize that these were the wrong
people to mess with and if they're gonna
keep fighting what about fighting these
two all at once this is a movie isn't it
did you have that gun along all these
reporters scrambling to get near em for
sound bite or somehow forgetting the
last five minutes of press conference
evidence that he does in fact cause
cancer
oh Jesus does dr. Manhattan know
everybody's address or did those people
all die or are they on Vulcan right now
or what yep the eyeglasses in the breast
pocket survive the ass beating of a
dozen hooligans because reasons
getting max well lady YouTube did
willingly walk into a dark alley just
after noting how bad a part of town you
were in so this movie is 22 flashbacks
15 flash-forwards and 850 if you know
where we are scenes all strung together
in random order this is basically what
happened to the home right also what
made this door closed what's that demon
from Paranormal Activity isn't it the
program's locked in we can't override
the time lock why the not holy it took
30 seconds for this clock to move 2
seconds pretty sure this is a flashback
within a flashback within a flashback
but even if it isn't the fact that I
think it is suggest the problem with the
movies concept of time yes John good
flashback exception John survives this
and gets stronger from it it's the only
photograph of me anyone has how is that
possible even in whatever the early
nineteen hundred's this is taking place
it be more than one photograph of
someone as smart and important as him
right if I'm to have this symbol it's
going to be the standard power button
icon from the early 2000s I see he
finally decided to cover up his dick for
now at least how did that conversation
go dr. Manhattan we'd love your input on
military endeavors but our scientists
find your large blue penis distracting
eally form superhero shows his strength
by destroying a tank cliche this
could've been handled a different way I
never said the Superman exists and he is
American yeah we know it was this guy
the news reporter that said that Cheney
tells me she is afraid and worried she
says I am like a god now she also tells
me how horrid our Christmas tree choices
were this year she's beautiful even
though I don't really have an interest
in this type of thing anymore I'll leave
my wife for a brand new woman for some
reason Janey accuses me of chasing
jailbait jeez how old is Malin Akerman
supposed to be and whatever year this is
that left no marks at all
this is straight-up murder but the guy
doesn't die so it's all okay if fight is
behind this fake assassination attempt
he must really hate his secretary and
Lee Iacocca
diagonal crossing that's super
jaywalking and I endorse any law
enforcement personnel that go after them
for it and there was something rewarding
in his eyes
this movie is telling me that Rorschach
is going to get vital information about
bites fake assassination from this
random street thug and this is a level
of omniscience I am NOT going to let sly
veidt's assassin was a local lowlife
named roy chess someone the cops never
thought to check after the assassination
attempt awesome reveal but how does
someone shoot this dude between the eyes
and leave him upright like this I mean
even if they manipulated the body after
death how'd they get that to sit up
straight
the amazing intuition of Veidt continues
as he sends out a random street thug he
knows Rorschach is going to find goes to
Mark's house and kills him and knows
within 15 minutes or so that Rorschach's
gonna be at Malik's house so he can
frame him for the murder dude on the
stairs just stands here doing nothing
while watching his fellow officers get
torched this asshole was full
stormtrooper you never go full
stormtrooper tell me what you see
Rorschach Rorschach Malkovich movie
inspires first Captain America movies
bully scene cheesiness was dark when the
murderer got back well yes it was dark
when you got here too so make sense but
go on with your bad narrating so would
do this upon finding their home broken
into anyone with a brain no that's what
I thought I mean dude you're standing in
all the light oh who is it asking these
questions is maybe stupider than barging
in here in the first place well this is
something the prison shrink might say
it's not something he'd say did a
low-life guarding the door he'd say it
to the warden or a judge or his wife
anyone but this gasps holding the door
open for him
whoa this prison is serving french fries
I thought all prison food was inedible
but french fries
maybe I should revisit a few of my caper
ideas excellent demonstration of power
but still did you have to do it on
French Friday this is a dumb thing to do
yeah I just need a couple minutes
three-hour movie has time for the hero
can't get it up storyline in this dream
these two have sex on Mars for some
reason
hey where's the bone from that guy's
boner huh
new costume contemplation I used to be a
masked Avenger too remember marvel
certainly does not remember every time
some crime-fighting has to be done
there's a full moon out yet another
comic book movie where the heroes have
to save children from a fire okay first
of all this is cheesy and stupidest
second of all Jesus doesn't wear al
costumes third of all Jesus and space
rockets are almost completely in
Congress at this point in scientific
advancement north of all space rocket
how are they gonna get all these people
in this super small ship probably
through editing and never showing you
the back of the ship luckily the power
of slow motion will prevent Silk Spectre
from third-degree burns having delivered
the fire survivors to a vacant lot
behind a tall fence the two superheroes
fly off to each other's brains out I
think both actors are hot here and I'm
down for a nudity riddled sex scene
between the two which is what we get but
this is one of the worst covers of
Leonard Cohen's Hallelujah I've ever
heard in my life
no seriously not sure if they were going
for it but movie definitely wins
weirdest sex scene of the decade award
and this movie came out the same decade
a storytelling as these two banging each
other's brains out I'm left to wonder
hey why is the moon so goddamn big his
purse all mighty in town also be which
one of the hundreds of dr. Manhattan's
cloned around the solar system teeth
ache so this fire gasm these guys
somehow have a power saw to cut this
guy's arms off but couldn't smuggle in a
gun or a knife why didn't they just do
this at the very beginning why would
they waiting outside so long also is he
plugging this thing up right there like
a thousand times too many book pages
strewn about for you know a prison riot
because tearing out single pages of a
book right now
then why and why they throwing that all
over the place Oh prison riot and only
this douchebag and his henchmen are
after worship not bloody likely not
after what we were told earlier but
whatever go on with your
paint-by-numbers Rorschach escape what
did you expect dude do you not know what
Rorschach can do why is this such a
shock yeah but Mickey added from
Seinfeld actually had an attack that
could defeat Rorschach he'd lose two to
one but Rorschach would be dead so he's
alive I can tell Rorschach is alive by
looking at this dead body that isn't him
it was this video game in Japan running
out of his cell when the entire prison
is rioting on the other end of the
hallway was he just hanging out in a
Cell waiting for somebody to fight my
expert gun handling skills telling me to
point the gun two feet away from you and
get distracted by any little thing it's
use me have to visit men's room why does
workshop go from using definite articles
to not using definite articles either
they're important to him or they're not
and to the street shows offs will be
drawing fire soon oh okay whatever that
means some super old dude just busted
Rorschach out of prison
he lives over a garage right near here
Florent how does this guy know this and
how convenient is it that they're this
close while having this conversation
I know this and what Hollis calls silk
spectres mom and suddenly 2.25 hours
into this thing we're suddenly supposed
to care about the older generation of
heroes in this film who I thought were
somewhere between useless filler and
unnecessary backstory also the presence
of carla Gugino is doing nothing to make
this movie feel less Sin City like it's
hard for me to believe these guys think
this older version of night owl is the
guy who beat them up in the alley
earlier but even harder to believe that
after such an ass-kicking they'd want to
try to fight this guy again if you
already know the future then why were
you surprised when I left you Silk
Spectre would be excellent at cinemasins
when you left me I left Earth but she
left you for good reason and you had
multiple other yous off doing sine while
you were making love to her how do you
have any feelings at all dude since this
Veidt enterprises computer is in the
pyramid building do they even need to
look for who's behind this hey Rorschach
this computer sister fight enterprises
hey I bet I know who's behind this how
bad is this guy's password if it's the
same as one of the three books on his
desk I guess since it's 1985
intelligence hasn't been invented yet
oh no information I already should have
known by simple observation nice shot
but realize we didn't hear a bunch of
bodies hitting the floor after they
drank poison so it's almost like it
didn't happen
Ozymandias commits a mass murder and yet
the most puzzling thing in the scene is
the sudden mythological rhino tiger
hyena is this thing as he had it all
along and i just never noticed it I
cannot imagine a more dangerous opponent
except for dr. Manhattan maybe that
little trick that Manhattan just
performed on Laurie showed her nothing
about what he sees or how he understands
things it was a hypnotist trick to bring
back repressed memories but
understanding him not why is this thing
falling apart I submit it's only because
all-powerful dr. Manhattan is allowing
it to fall apart as further evidence in
his quest to get Silk Spectre to turn
her back on earth because he's
all-powerful
he could stop it if he wanted well you
smile if I had
I was wrong wait what you're just gonna
take the blame because she's crying up
until now you were an emotionless South
just end up already
turning the air in the cold okay I was
gonna send the weird Vietnam war movie
anthem but a smiley face on Mars that is
worth five sins and I think I'm being
lenient these idiots still somehow think
they've gotten this far undetected since
I have no idea what awesome Andy is his
powers are this fight should be fun
right yeah Sunday Moscow Hong Kong 15
million people killed what you're gonna
disintegrate those four cities and only
kill 15 million humanity's savage nature
will inevitably lead to global
innovation oh hi there Ultron you're
about a decade early killing millions to
save billions without having seen this
movie before I assume dr. Manhattan is
going to come back with his girlfriend
to save the day at oz he's gonna be all
like but I totally plan for you to come
back and then Manhattan's gonna be all
like cruising woman's I totally
predicted that too and then the good
guys will win yet is this thing director
put another reference to his last hit in
this movie still not nearly the damage
Superman did in Man of Steel well I've
never seen more dick in a mainstream
movie that's for sure
sure I'm familiar with this guy's dick
by now isn't that fun I think it's fun
I guess it's totally logical that dr.
Manhattan would survive this since his
human form also survived this but why
didn't I see man Diaz think of that and
isn't it kind of stupid he walked into
this place as one man when we've seen
him split himself into as many as six
Manhattan's in this movie send in the
clones so in other words you took this
giant tumble down the stairs for no
reason giant dr. Manhattan this terrible
at scooping to superpowers for treating
from law let's talk about Aziz plan it
required an intricate series of things
to go right for it to work all to kill
millions of people just so the US and
USSR wouldn't kill billions with nuclear
weapons why not simply ask dr. Manhattan
to disarm all the world's nukes before
they could be fired with their
considerable resources and power and
that's not that big of an ask is it then
you could blame Manhattan for disarming
the nukes and unite behind that rather
than millions died and I feel like there
are hundred other things he could have
done before this that we don't have time
to discuss in one video no so much
punching so very much punching I know
that Eddie Blake was my father
definitely needed to tie up this knot
loose end before the three-hour movie
end it definitely yeah
I'm so relieved no seriously
huh alcoholism am i right
hey just like this button at the
beginning I get it sure is lucky
Rorschach left his diary at the one
newspaper that needed to find a story
from its crank file maybe you should
have made a stop at Kinkos and
distributed more copies than one yeah
you're right this one newspaper was all
you needed
nothing it's just that all men are sure
it never happened to them and most women
at one time or another have done it so
you knew the math what he expect the
comedian's dead
hello darkness my old friend we're here
we're queer we don't want anymore bears
go make yourself a drink and I'll be
down in two shakes of a lamb's tail what
about Janey Slater you think it makes a
difference to her Jenny Slater yeah hey
J Slater really good a Jenny Slater I
feel like the maid I just cleaned up
this mess could we keep it clean for for
10 minutes these are the yummiest
cookies I've ever had feeling
lightheaded and the waiter standing
behind hand at the top of the stairs
bowtie 12 o'clock he broke in here Max
Headroom it is February 12th 1981 in 11
years it's gonna be 1984 man think about
that
I forget
gentleman you can't fight in here this
is the war room not a mark on her you'd
have the Jag repulsor notice those
perfect breasts of hers aren't moving
like they would if she was breathing mr.
Gale closing cameras down we got a riot
going on in the rec room in me wings